hey guys I'm Ryan right oh I'm Jerry
we're gonna watch the trailer for Middle
Earth shadow of Mordor the brightlord
story trailer whoa it's a mouthful
yeah I've been liking the trailers I've
been seeing so far this is a video it's
a video oh oh and I though I've said it
before spin-offs of this videogame look
like they'd actually be good like if
they ever went Star Wars on Lord of the
Rings these would be good spin-offs all
right I'm excited I know nothing about
this other than what I know about the
Lord of the Rings universe they should
cross the Lord of the Rings universe and
the Star Wars universe somehow it could
sort of work if it's not cheesy as [ __ ]
it could somehow work I yeah it doesn't
it doesn't altogether not make sense
oh yeah I mean it's middle-earth in and
like there versus Italy
it's a galaxy moving man it's a space
opera yeah cool that be I'd be pretty
interesting Han Solo hanging out with
those trees yeah
han Solo in the ends yeah I don't must
call them ents emts no ents and yours no
the throat Oh blood and gore and intense
violence
be wary it's true Charlie just to go
not of this world let his mark on him
Isis you feel he has answers
I do not trust him
do not wish to know why
remember broken images yes now our
bracelet attend your family perhaps on
pain vitamin ceaseless dreams they offer
no answers only more questions are not
your dreams my power grows stronger me
you add accomplish such bond
involved try to smith the second date
I'd heard the stories but I remember my
name I shaped the history of
middle-earth I crafted the Rings of
Power oh can you trace the mud like that
a few people my power gifts the Gateway
to defeating the Dark Lord
- no Sveta's systems among which one
first
oh [ __ ] okay I like the first review
they put up is a blocks the play really
fun yeah like it doesn't get that vibe
at all yeah definitely it's a blast
no there's a good time but know that
please God in my whole life there's
nothing I've ever asked for more okay
thank you move into my to you nothing
more important in this book maybe Lapham
said okay so anyway so yeah that movie
what a game looks like it means just
cinematic trailer yeah it's a cool story
like that's what I had as stories cool
like I want to play just for the story
even though I know it's not from what
are you doing you're yawning during my
time on dog and iron I'm sorry dude what
the [ __ ]
I that is rude try to hide that yawn I
did put my fist and they be you totally
like I didn't value to do though I was
more that's because I was more concern
was listening and I was like oh [ __ ] I'm
yawning I put Jesus cherry Jesus cherry
but Jesus Jerry's joke it's cool as he
call them involved in this I mean it
sounds like it's Andy Serkis I'm sure it
is yeah and then all the awards its
winning mm-hmm I hope you get to play as
go I'll be cool they should make
whatever you play as god I should make
like like just a side quest where you
have to go catch fish
what if Gollum and Yoda cross paths that
would be funky that'd be cool I guess
okay green creatures that is what I'm
like awesome oh dude that's great thank
you
yeah one more time that's awesome it do
it I want to see it dance a monkey that
lights up Asif one happy fault that one
was bigger than I can do a really good
goal in like half the time yeah I know
she mean oh and I like the story of them
of Haven being the guy who actually
built the links
cuz yeah the thing is it I have no idea
I forgot I don't have the greatest
working knowledge of the Laura always
thought set on build Emerson that's what
I thought too but they never actually
establish you built the ring
you know a solution terms the movie I I
don't I don't know about the actual book
because I started reading it I want to
watch that I got really bored well
there's a lot of description cuz his he
writes those books as though they're
history book I almost want to go back
and at least rewatch the intro because I
forget like I could've sworn he made
them and then he made this one because
he's like Isis I made this stuff though
I'm gonna have the most powerful oh okay
well I don't I could be wrong like my my
brain functions aren't firing right now
I don't know are we gonna get on this
and then Johnny Depp as Eragon
Aragorn Gorn yeah that'd be weird that
would be very strange live just because
he's not the same kind of actors we got
more to hold the king there would be at
least one moment we're like some kind of
creature gets stabbed in front of him
and he's just like he'll do that thing
where he he looks at it was it really
wide eyes we must pick up he gets creeks
gavel oh yeah anyway
wasn't for this weekend if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
rejects that's what we call ourselves
those are badasses yeah we spray paint
walls and [ __ ] Oh lead lion was here
yeah it's that legit tags where was he
here who we read conversations and
differing colors
yeah and Jerry has a playlist called
reasons Jerry I do and it is crazy ass
[ __ ] on there I'm talking barbecues and
then people getting caught on fire and
then two people having sex while caught
on fire yeah hosting a lot of things I
don't I'm just posting and putting it on
your playlist oh good anyway Jerry you
know what time of the video it's 9:30 no
9:25 douche oh sorry Alex Pollak hey
Ryan
do you mind giving a 56 year old man
that weighs 300 pounds with one arm and
a glass eye shoutout oh can I get one
too
misdirection what do you mean I think he
was setting it up as though like oh wow
you're 56 years old and 304 and you have
one arm oh wow oh and can I get one too
huh dad I'm pretty sure this is a real
person I may be I mean maybe he does
know a 300-pound 56 year old man who's
missing an arm but I have a feeling the
whole oh and can I get one too is like a
joke that's how it reads anyway
Alex Pollak I'm sorry if it's not the
case but hey I just don't like liars I
am an A if you guys if you have a friend
who is 56 300 pounds and missing an arm
if there's one movie that really
delivers a message its liar liar cuz
that's what that message is people not
to lie ever ever even if there's a fire
Devon the spider-man of youth
interesting Ryan can I get a shout-out
sure Devon the spider-man of youth I
haven't heard of you before it's an odd
name yeah the spider-man so wait you are
you protector of youth but you're an
adult or are you actually part of the
youth are you just the spider-man that
people remember from their childhoods
but his name's Peter Parker why would it
be done in worldly being yeah Jerry if
the acts don't line up oh maybe this is
a mystery we have to solve this could be
national treasure 3 if we wanted it to
be
yeah this area's name - who Devon is is
hidden on the back of the Bill of Rights
or something oh it's just the first clue
of many though yeah but we spent 45
minutes working on the first good read
the emancipation proclamation vertically
instead of horizontally it tells you the
secret destiny of Devon the spider-man
of youth Chi Diggs can I please get a
shout out you're my [ __ ] you're my
[ __ ] bro all right bro [ __ ] he said
you're my bro hmm you're my [ __ ] Chi
Diggs
you my [ __ ] ouch you do what I want you
to do Chi does your mom I don't know how
are you crea sorry photo man if you are
- yo you or your son Oh Chi I am sorry I
am sorry if you were young if you
a young boy then kahe or awesome beyond
belief and can do it you can do it
whatever one would ever even want to do
just get up mash future you're a
beautiful snowflake yeah thanks for
watching thanks for watching and no I
won't make you my [ __ ] when you're
older unless you're already old and he
probably unless you're already older
than the Apple right a country